hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one very
important topic for us I certainly for
virtue ethics that comes up and Nick
McCann ethics book six is the question
about what the relationship is between
what we might say forms of intellectual
excellence and forms of moral excellence
or if you want to put it in more
determinant form what is the
relationship between wisdom prudence is
prudence is indeed something different
than wisdom and virtue or the virtues
Aristotle is writing against a backdrop
in which as he notes Socrates has taught
something quite different
Socrates coming to him through Plato's
own writings and of course Plato's own
teaching since Aristotle was a student
of Plato Socrates had said that the
virtues themselves were something like
kinds of knowledge or types of
principles and that wisdom itself was
one of the virtues in fact it was needed
in order to have the other virtues in
some of the dialogues you'll see not
only wisdom and soft being being
discussed but some of the other virtues
being arranged in terms of being guided
by wisdom or
sometimes even said to be knowledge or
wisdom about certain things and so
aerosol is trying to differentiate his
view apart from that of Socrates and by
extension that Plato this is also I
would say is something that sets
Aristotle apart from his his stoic
interlocutors who are going to come on
the scene afterwards but interlocutors I
mean their their writing and response to
him not that he's actually talking with
them so in Aristotle's way of
understanding us wisdom and prudence are
two different intellectual dispositions
wisdom even remember he has to do with
the higher part of the highest part of
the soul of the rational part of the
soul
Aristotle had divided the rational part
of the soul into two parts the higher
part dealt with things that were eternal
or these whose principles were not
changing so you know for example the
heavens or the the nature's of things
right the the universals that we can
study and wisdom indeed was was quite
expansive we've got video specifically
on that prudence deals with the whole
realm of the practical sphere where we
do our most of our living as well as
much of our thinking now it doesn't
encompass everything but it is a kind of
what we call practical wisdom an
understanding of what is good for human
beings in in a variety of different ways
and so wisdom and prudence
well Plato would often use these rather
synonymously Arizona wants to split them
apart and say look one deals with one
type of thing which really is good for
human beings another deals with the
practical good practical life what we
need to do what decisions we need to
make how we need to prioritize waiting
goods against each other deal with
difficult situations now we consider
several different objections that might
be made
about saying that prudence has something
to do with moral virtue if by the way in
the Aristotle's view wisdom really is
not going to have much to do with moral
virtue because it's concerned just with
the things that are higher than than
human beings prudence is seemingly
concerned at the realm of moral virtue
but some people might raise some
objections so one of these would be
local produce focuses on the goods for a
human being they are a kind of
abbreviating because Aristotle actually
says on the beautiful and the just and
the good and the useful all these ranges
of value permanent takes into account
prudence presumably can say something
meaningful about those Aristotle says
though does knowing about those sorts of
things actually make us more apt to do
those things the term there is a
practical thorough a more practical more
reliable to get things done so think
back to Nick ohmic an ethics book to
where Aristotle
raised a criticism that many
philosophers have had to raise ethics
which is simply reading the book is not
going to make you a good person simply
developing some knowledge about you know
what's good and what's bad and why it's
good why it's bad we move sometimes
dey'd book smarts versus street smarts
are practical manners proven if prudence
really boils down to just being able to
give the right answer at the right time
it doesn't really make us ready to do
things then when we require the virtues
he has at misses in order to do
something maybe the virtues would be
guided by the prudence in a certain
sense or informed by it because it would
tell them what to do but the virtues
would be doing the heavy lifting
Aristotle doesn't think that's right but
you don't want to consider that view
here's another interesting question yeah
well what about you know let's say
prudence really is useful in helping
wanted to become virtuous what good is
it
you become virtuous isn't it more like a
ladder that after you climb up will you
throw away you don't need it after after
you become virtuous because you've got
these habits and you're gonna operate
according to the habits you don't need
to think things out anymore
in order to make them work but the
Arizona will also reject that notion as
well third maybe prudence is not really
useful for the the not yet virtuous or
the people who are not virtuous why well
they usually listen to somebody else
who's got prudence they don't need to
acquire it themselves
your soul says hey when you go to the
doctor now this may not apply to some of
you if you're a little obsessive that's
the thing when you go to the doctor you
don't need to get your medical degree
right you just need to find out what the
doctor has to say about what you need to
do in a particular situation similarly
you know it comes to like coaching right
clients don't need to know everything
that you know in order for in a
particular this discussion you to give
them some useful guidance about how they
might think out what the right thing is
to do there's many cases where we don't
need expert you know knowledge we just
need expert advice maybe Prudence's like
that we can just sort of consult
somebody else who's prudent and get the
advice that we need and then we're okay
Arizona projects all of those imperfect
because they get pretty strong they also
get virtually as we pointed out earlier
on there are subtle discusses this in
what two of the nikah mechanics to be
virtuous means to act in the right ways
that is to act the way the virtuous
person does which is to act in
accordance with right principle which is
to act the way the prudent person does
so there is an intrinsic connection for
Aristotle between prudence and the
virtues in fact he goes so far
to suggest that it might actually be the
case that you can't really deep root it
without possessing virtues and on the
other hand you can't possess virtues
without being prudent that's a subject
matter for a different discussion but
it's an interesting one nonetheless
Aristotle says prudence is needed in
addition to the other virtues and
remember prudence is a intellectual
virtue the other virtues are the moral
or ethical virtues why he says virtue
gives the right aim when we're trying to
find out what we're supposed to do the
scope owes in that passage and other
places he'll talk about virtue supplying
the principle the Archaea the starting
point so in virtue as a habit it puts us
in the right starting frame to to
apprehend what's going on in the
situation and it helps us see what we
want to be doing so if I I'm going to be
generous my aim in generosity is not to
be a big shot and throw my money around
or just to make myself feel good by
doing retail therapy it's actually to
have that money to do some good for
other people they're going to do
something noble so virtue gives the
right aim he says that prudence yes what
is related to that right name
this is translated in some translations
as you know virtue gives the end
prudence gives the means to the end that
that's actually technically correct but
what Aristotle is actually saying there
is top cross-cut on the things that are
in relation to that
so prudence helps you attend to all of
the other particulars in the situation
that matter you might say that prudence
is the governor that makes virtue act
the way that it should entirely without
a prudence virtue wouldn't be entirely
virtuous monotonous on saying now this
inference that I'm dry Aristotle also
says look virtue cooperates with right
principle he says and as with reason
right it is not itself reason but it
cooperates with right principle and in
practical matters of conduct what is
right principle it is prudence this is
why that Aristotle says that the
virtuous person does what they do in
accordance with prudence earlier on in
the Nicomachean ethics so prudence is
actually going to be required at least
to some degree perhaps one will be
totally improvement but it'll be
required to some degree in order for a
person to be virtuous and in order for
those virtues to be applied in the right
way at the right time with all of the
various rights that we talked about so
again
Aristotle splits up practical wisdom or
prudence from from speculative wisdom or
Sophia and I am prudence is you might
say it's in some respects the
architectonic virtue that makes all the
other virtues possible that keeps them
on the right track so it plays an
incredibly important role within
Aristotle's ethics a person cannot
really be thoroughly in all respect to
good person without having cultivated
the virtue of prudence